the Counter-Strike Community was shocked
this past weekend when config who had
been sidelined from the astralis roster
for weeks revealed that his ankle had
been broken as part of a fist fight in
Malta a serious ankle break requiring
multiple surgeries delaying his return
home and not to mention having to work
through the consequences of this
life-changing injury it's a harrowing
tale and one that we finally have in the
man's own words so let's dig in
before we get into the video I just want
to warn you that it does contain
descriptions of violence as well as
severe physical and mental anguish I
understand if you're not equipped today
to take that on I do feel it's important
to look at accounts like these but
you're important too so don't push
yourself and feel free to punch out now
if you need to okay so if you're still
with me let's dive in what actually
happened here Christian vinica better
known by his Alias config is a 25 year
old Danish CS go rifler and during the
incident we're about to discuss he was a
member of astralis's Cs go roster
astralis traveled to Malta in September
to attend ESL Pro League season 16's
group stage as one of that League's
permanent Partners however they missed
the cut for playoffs behind complexity
in group C so they were basically done
for this tournament shortly after the
group stage though astralis announced
that config had suffered a complicated
ankle fracture and would be replaced by
Mister for the upcoming coming RMR event
this was a little strange maybe but I
mean it is possible to break your ankle
or foot just from stepping off a curb
strangely still it kind of seemed like
it could be more serious than that and
nobody was saying why or how it happened
that is until Christian slot of a news
Outlet Jackson reported that config had
been in a fist fight in Malta and that
he would be removed from the astralis
roster I think it's important to clarify
that the initial Jackson report did not
link the broken ankle explicitly to the
fist fight although it did mention the
astralis Tweet about it config then
tweeted a reply to the article where he
claimed that he was previously contacted
by Jackson with rumors that were quote
mostly BS two weeks later and after much
speculation across the Cs go Community
config told his side of the story in the
twit longer he confirmed that the fist
fight did happen and it was the cause of
the broken ankle he said he was trying
to rejoin his teammates at a club after
grabbing some food on his own but when
he got to the door a club promoter
dissed his tattoos refused him entry
unless he paid 5 000 Euros for a table
and things got a little heated when they
exchanged words config said that this
promoter spat directly in his face and
then kicked him in the head not a
difficult feat considering that the
entrance of the club was at the top of
the staircase and this guy was standing
a couple stairs above the kicks sent him
down the stairs and sprained his ankle
config said while the promoter scurried
inside config said that he was nursing
his swollen face and sore ankle trying
to keep his emotions in check when he
saw the club promoter then leave the
club in a hurry and he decided to
confront him by convicts telling he told
the promoter that he'd be reported to
the police and the promoter then again
spat directly in his face
side note who spits in people's faces
nowadays before the fight began in
Earnest but config said that his leg was
fully broken during this altercation and
as he lay on the ground the promoter was
trying to kick him in the head and he
couldn't get away because of the leg he
wrote quote I tried to run away but I
couldn't put weight on my right leg it
just snapped and broke completely
dislocating my foot as well he stopped
kicking me because I dragged him down to
me and I had to do self-defense to make
him stop kicking me I was so scared that
I was about to die I remember feeling
like I was watching my own body from
above laying there thankfully that
wasn't what happened but somebody nearby
had to call an ambulance for config
because the promoter had apparently
stolen his phone before fleeing from a
hospital in Malta config said that he
wanted to return to Denmark to get the
necessary surgeries but he was warned
that because of damage to his orbital
bone it might not be possible to fly
without causing damage to his right eye
due to pressure changes but eventually
he was clear to fly he was able to make
it back home and doctors in Denmark
confirmed that he would need surgery in
order to repair his ankle he underwent
two surgeries the first two stabilize
the foot using rods
Etc the second to actually put a plate
into his shin to kind of tie the whole
thing together including pushing some of
the muscle back into place the physical
damage he said was excruciating the
mental burden was pretty bad too he said
quote I can't explain how bad these days
have been my sleep was non-existing I
was sleeping around one to two hours a
night and was constantly scared and when
I hit deep sleep I would wake up feeling
like someone was trying to drag my legs
and pull me out of the bed I had night
terrors waking up drenched in sweat and
still have almost every single night but
even after the final surgery was done he
said the mental toll continued quote
when I came home I broke down crying I
couldn't see the light at the end of the
tunnel it felt so bad that I
just wanted to delete everything and
just give up I couldn't stop crying I
was in my own bed feeling empty the
entire time I was hospitalized thoughts
had been in my mind is this the time to
end my career is this it for me but this
is nowhere near the end for me I'm going
to war against myself now no I'm not
going anywhere call me sentimental if
you want but for me this is a pretty
poignant account of one person facing
extreme hardship and just trying to find
the strength to push through that
situation and keep going I got emotional
reading it he's clearly struggling but
he's also resolved to get some help and
to eventually return to Counter-Strike
regarding the decision to confront the
Promoter on the street config said quote
I regret this terribly I should have
walked away I should have just gone home
and licked my wounds because then none
of this had happened that's the right
thing to say and config would also go on
to accept responsibility for his part in
this confrontation which is good and
listen I'm more into Street Fighter the
game than street fighting the activity
so I'm no expert on physical fights but
from what I've seen fights are brutal
messy and often over quick even just
falling can hurt or kill a human being
if the right set of circumstances emerge
so you add trying to do active harm to
another person into that and things can
spiral out of control pretty quickly
chasing after the guy wasn't the right
call clearly and config admitted as much
but I will say even though the police
know who this person is and they are
investigating with config listed as a
victim that's called Comfort when you're
nursing your reconstructed leg back to
health more comforting perhaps were the
messages from the Cs go Community a lot
of people came out to support him in
this difficult time and it's another
reminder that at the end of the day this
is a sport and no one wants to see real
harm come to anyone even a competitor
he's taking responsibility for his
actions it is very easy to feel sorry
for yourself and to some degree you
should allow yourself to feel sorry
because losing your spot in Australia is
now being in a position where he
probably can't play Counter-Strike for a
month or so now I have to know for the
sake of fairness that even though config
replied to that Jackson story stating
that the rumors he was approached with
were quote mostly BS end quote we don't
know what those rumors were or if
they're represented in the piece that
they published what Jackson did publish
seems to line up perfectly with config's
account although admittedly it contains
far less detail and like I noted earlier
it doesn't explicitly link the ankle
break to the fist fight and Jackson
ended up taking a bit of a Victory lap
anyways to set the record straight okay
so config isn't giving up he said he
wants to become the god tier
Counter-Strike player that he knows he
can be so why exactly did he say that
config's career Could Have Ended as a
result of this event and for many fans
that would have been extremely
disappointing that's because config is
by his own admission even a player who
hasn't hit his full potential we've seen
very exciting Peaks but we haven't seen
that period of dominance in the past
he's admitted that he could have handled
the social part of Cs a bit better but
for the longest time the Danish riflers
Keen instincts and aggressive play seem
poised to set him apart then in 2017 he
had a bit of a breakout year he was
ranked 14th on the hltv top 20 players
list and then set the record for most
kills in regulation time against
Renegades in early 2018 as part of optic
with 47. kills he would eventually join
complexity and then finally astralis the
organization built by some of the
greatest players Denmark has ever
fielded in CS go and an obvious spot for
a rising star in CS but none of these
rosters ever really manage a level of
consistency that would allow config to
refine and Elevate his game so that's
one more reason why people are so
excited to see him commit to continuing
his career config and his fans don't
want this to end on a not quite
especially when we feel like the
potential is so much better than that
sure he's a lot better at Counter-Strike
than most and no one's disputing that
fact but even he feels like he can do
better in the future and he wants that
for himself we as fans want that too we
don't want a career cut short by a hasty
decision or regret and hell even if he
never makes it back to Pro play the
decision to keep going to keep learning
about yourself even in if that's a
difficult process is commendable and in
my opinion deeply human but I'm willing
to bet that he'll be back because a lot
of people want to know the answer to the
question how far can config go and I
think the person who wants that answer
the most is him
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock
foreign